I got nothing against the tubos the
chubbetts the fatties the lizos whatever
you want to call them but I look at fat
like smoking once you get smoke but once
you blow it into my face yeah now I'm
pissed and he's got secondhand fat in my
chair I got the gut and the arm yeah
he's all over me yeah
this next to someone who's taking up
more space than usual that I should be
allowed to lean on them and use them as
a pillow and they usually allow me
they're really nice about it like this
woman I had a 17-hour flight to
Melbourne and this woman was like look
I'm a big woman if you could just hop
over me to go go to the bathroom that'd
be great but also if you need to lean on
me you can I'm like thank you I don't
want to touch you I don't care she was
really sweet marshmallow people
sticky she wasn't she was really cozy
also can I just say so how about any
part of your body that's in my area is
mine
so I can draw on it yeah get markers to
draw whatever it's like mine yes right
and then when you leave it gets out of
my territory it's yours again I like it
but also you're a lovely lady whoa what
did she saying hot well I'm trying to
keep it professional yeah but if you
lean on a on a person it's different
than if uh me and this little egg roll
[Laughter]
I think so yeah
yeah other egg roll friends well the
problem you egg rolls you're always
working
all right yeah yeah yeah so I can't find
your healing blackjack or sitting on a
box peeling stuff
oh so your the egg rolls in New York
they sit on boxes and they peel things
oh my God you guys can squat like
nobody's oh so okay yeah I know you're
Korean but uh whoa I went to China yeah
and uh man they just squat that's like
comfortable yeah and they SWAT and smoke
yeah yeah oh we love it we love that
position I would just [__] was is Ronnie
Chang an egg rolling I love Ronnie
Jackson I love Shang Wang all the names
that sound racist
yeah yeah there's another New York guy I
don't know his name but I he's always on
my feed good looking kind of an Asian
dude good looking Asian seller never
heard of such a thing
Ali Wong's very attractive
if you work with your girl would you
penetrate her I would sure I'd love to
really
well can we is your hand isn't
penetration so nice
yeah it's so good strap-on yeah yeah
strap on it yeah yeah you've strapped
yeah yeah he's never let me strap
will you let your girl straps and then
[__] you in the ass no but you got strap
vibes
that [__] I've ever [__] heard
from you
salted with your open mind you've tried
everything you flew it baby yeah baby
let's just introduce him get the [__]
get through this [__] nightmare
nightmare I think hi don't worry about
him he's a chew right oh look at him he
should see his cut dick
is your dick cut
okay mine is too and I'm not Jewish oh
really yeah mine's yours yours mine's
not I like it all I I have a new
elephantitis yeah no no no my new thing
is uncut dick
that's your new thing now what's the
biggest difference for you no I wouldn't
I wouldn't I wouldn't circumcise my son
if I had one whoa oh I have uncut I love
uncut vag yeah where where that Wall's
still there what's that wall where you
penetrate labia majora yeah oh the thing
the football players run through
no
what about you Napoleon Dynamite
yeah you you don't look good
you don't look good at all you look cool
what do you want to see you look stupid
anyway uh let's start